how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and of course the MCU
now even though unfortunately due to the
coronavirus Marvel has had to adjust
their schedule a little bit and delay
some upcoming productions as well
however nothing is going to fully stop
Marvel from eventually releasing all of
their titles and today we're going to
talk about something that I know many
fans have been waiting for for a very
long time Ghost Rider in the MCU and not
only the possibility of Ghost Rider
entering the MCU but him entering in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and possibly Keanu Reeves
playing the part if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all things relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers now obviously this
is super exciting news
Ghost Rider coming to the MCU but what
is really interesting is where this
report is coming from you all may
remember the Twitter account Rodger at
Ward L he's the person that leaked a ton
of information about Avengers in game
all of which ended up being 100% true
literally everything that he said months
before Avengers endgame came out that
was going to happen happened and he's
been quiet for a while but a new account
has popped up instead of Roger Ward L it
is called Ward L Roger with the same
name
Roger Ward L it's widely believed that
this is his new account and he was
locked out of his old one most likely
for leaking very accurate information
about the MCU and in his new report he
has tweeted return of the dark hold will
be fundamental for upcoming wan division
captain britain and Ghost Rider in
Doctor Strange 2 events of both the show
and movie will prepare the ground for
dr. Doom's debut so as you can see here
according to this new Roger Ward L
account there is a lot coming to the MCU
so let's break this down piece by piece
starting with the dark hold the dark
hold also known as the book of sins or
the book of spells is an ancient book of
spells and unspeakable power this book
was created by dark matter from hell
it is said to contain infinite knowledge
and over the course of history in the
comics many people have searched for it
including Red Skull Daniel Whitehall and
Nick Fury himself now the very
interesting part about this
port is that Roger Wardell says that the
Darkhold is going to be fundamental for
the upcoming one division series and
based off of everything that we know
there is going to be a connection to it
we know that the one division series is
going to explore more of the actual
Scarlet Witch and her powers we also
know that Agatha Harkness is going to be
in the Wan division series as well and
in the comics she's an actual witch who
helps and trains Wanda and it's pretty
much all but confirmed that this is the
character that Kathryn Hahn is going to
be playing in the series not to mention
we also have some leaked photos of the
one division series of the Salem witches
so in this series they're going to
explore more of Wanda as a witch there's
going to be actual spells and as you can
see there will be other witches in this
series as well which means one of them
will most likely have the dark hold or
mephesto the ruler of the Hell dimension
himself could even make an appearance
after all he is deeply connected to
Doctor Doom but more about that when we
talk about Doctor Doom the next part of
this report says Captain Britain and
Ghost Rider in Doctor Strange - Ghost
Rider and Doctor Strange - is something
that fans have been predicting and
wanting for a pretty long time
especially if Doctor Strange - is going
to explore more of the mystic side now
most people know that there are many
different versions of Ghost Rider but
for this sake we're going to be talking
about Johnny Blaze and the reason for
that is because of the connection with
mephesto in order to save the life of
his father stunt motorcyclist Johnny
Blaze agreed to give his soul to Satan
who of course was later revealed to be
an arch demon named
mephesto this turned him into the
supernatural Ghost Rider
now Johnny blazes Ghost Rider is widely
believed to be one of the most powerful
Marvel characters ever created in fact
in the world war hulk series it was
stated by Doctor Strange himself that
Ghost Rider might be equally as powerful
as the green scar persona of Hulk and
could possibly defeat him and now it
seems like he's going to be making his
official MCU debut in multiverse of
madness which is something that Kevin
Feige has briefly hinted at in an
interview a few months ago when he was
speaking about Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness he did mention
that we are going to be getting a new
character and this is what he said in
the interview sometimes you're choosing
a title hero choosing which main care
or main team you want to bring to the
screen and oftentimes it's as you're
making and developing the movie asking
who will come into it and who will fit
into it
the next Doctor Strange film for
instance features some new MCU
characters which will be making their
debut in that movie you won't expect or
won't guess who it is but we found a
cool way to make it work because we want
to make a particular type of movie there
and there was a character who we always
wanted to do something with who will fit
really well there and that's coming
directly from the president of Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige and it sounds like
the way that they're going to make this
character work is perhaps through one
division and the Darkhold it's very
clear that spells and witches are going
to be involved in the series but whether
or not mephesto is actually going to be
making an appearance is unknown yet
however it does seem to be going this
way although he may not be portrayed as
a Satan like figure but eventually
Johnny Blaze goes on to learn that he
has been bonded with the demon zarathos
and this is right around dr. Strange's
alley as he normally deals with
extra-dimensional demon spirits and
deities so Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness could be the
perfect opportunity to introduce Johnny
Blaze and according to Roger Wardell
it's going to happen now recently you
may have heard rumors that Keanu Reeves
is in talks to play Ghost Rider a role
that I think many fans would definitely
be excited to see him play and we do
know that Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios
have been meeting with Keanu Reeves
about the perfect role for him to play
to finally get him in the MCU and Kevin
Feige has even recently admitted this he
said that they meet with Keanu for every
movie that they make discussing every
possible character that he could play
unfortunately they haven't found the
perfect role for him yet which is why we
haven't seen him in the MCU but perhaps
they have found that perfect role with
Ghost Rider
this is the same thing that happened
with Jake Gyllenhaal Kevin Feige said
that they met with him many different
times until they finally found the role
of Mysterio which was perfect for him
and then they cast him it sounds like
that may be the case for Keanu Reeves
and Ghost Rider and perhaps he could be
making his appearance and Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness then the
account reported that Captain Britain is
going to be making his debut in
multiverse of madness as well now it was
actually expected that Captain
Britain could make his MCU debut and
Spiderman fire from home because they
mentioned the multiverse for those of
you who do not know Captain Britain has
a very deep connection to the multiverse
his real name is Brian Braddock and
after getting into a motorcycle accident
Merlin the great magician and his
daughter Roma appeared to him and offer
him the opportunity to become Captain
Britain he takes the responsibility in
Roma and Merlin grant him the powers and
also the responsibility of protecting
Britain in the earth-616 universe or the
main Marvel Comics universe he would
later go on to find out that he was part
of the Captain Britain Corps the Captain
Britain core consists of other captain
Britons from other universes and
collectively they are responsible for
protecting the multiverse and since
spider-man far from home name-dropped
multiverse we all thought that he was
going to appear however we know that
Mysterio was lying but that is all
changed now thanks to dr. strange in the
multiverse of madness we know that the
multiverse is very real and is coming
and not to mention there was a major
Easter Egg for Captain Britain in
Avengers endgame when Tony and Steve
Rogers go back in time to camp Lehi or
the birthplace of Captain America Steve
is trying to avoid being spotted and in
order to do that he hides in a random
office of course this turns out to be
the office of Peggy Carter and he ends
up spotting her through the window of
the office speaking with another agent
it was a very heartfelt moment which
made people not really pay attention to
the conversation that was being had
between Peggy and the other agent but in
this conversation Peggy Carter mentioned
something about someone named Braddock
who hasn't checked in yet now due to the
fact that this is in 1970 it's probably
not referring to Brian Braddock but most
likely referring to his father his
father Sir James and mother Lady
Elizabeth worked in a laboratory when
there was an accident and they were both
killed
and since Peggy says Braddock hasn't
checked in yet this could be referring
to the laboratory accident in which his
father is killed so in Avengers in game
they name-drop Braddock a captain in
Britain Easter Egg and then in the very
next MCU film spider-man far from home
they tease the multiverse now of course
the multiverse wasn't really involved
but now we have Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness which will
introduce the true multi
and according to this report will also
introduce captain britain and clearly
this lines up and makes a ton of sense
because if the multiverse is going to be
involved the captain britain core is
most likely going to be involved as well
and then the final report from this
account is that dr. doom will eventually
be introduced as well and the events
that take place in the one division
series and multiverse of madness will
set him up now dr. doom is an extremely
powerful sorcerer and so was his mother
and they both have a connection to what
everybody else seems to have a
connection to here and that is mephesto
Victor Von Doom aka dr. Jim's mother
Cynthia Von Doom was a very talented
witch she was a good person who tried to
protect her people but due to being
tricked by mephesto ends up being locked
in hell this leads to dr. doom making a
deal with mephesto that if he can defeat
him he'll let his mother go dr. doom has
yet to defeat mephesto however mephesto
has let cynthia von doom go up to a
higher plane
sometimes enabling contact between
Victor Von Doom and his mother it's
widely believed that Cynthia Von Doom is
going to be introduced during the Salem
witch trials in one division and since
it's likely that the dark hold and
mephesto are going to be introduced
during that series as well or Doctor
Strange and multiverse of madness it
seems like Cynthia Von Doom will end up
being stuck in one of my festas realms
this will undoubtedly lead to the
introduction of Victor Von Doom
Cynthia's son who of course will later
go on to become dr. doom not to mention
that the Fantastic Four are getting
their own movie as well very soon and
dr. doom is a classic Fantastic Four
villain but dr. doom is one of the
greatest Marvel villains of all time so
his role will no doubt be much larger
than just a fantastic four villain he
will no doubt be one of the big bads
that is coming to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so let me know what you think
about this report let me know what you
think about Ghost Rider and the fact
that Keanu Reeves could be playing him
Captain Britain and Victor Von Doom be
sure to comment down below and like this
video also don't forget to subscribe and
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to Marvel
and the MCU for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof
you